Hey Conan 360 Live,
this is John Karounos
from Warner Bros. Studio Tour Hollywood.
I'm currently inside of
the picture car vault
or as I like to call it
The Bat Cave.
I'm gonna show you around
some of my absolute
favorite things.
Follow me over to this Batmobile here.
Now, what you see is the
Batmobile from Batman Forever.
That's where Val Kilmer
played Bruce Wayne and Batman.
Crazy fact, the radio
in here is stuck forever
on Seal's Kiss From A Rose.
It's the only thing that
plays inside of the car.
We also have the bikes
from Batman and Robin.
We have Robin's Redbird,
We have Batgirl's Batblade.
We also have the original,
the number one hero car from Batman, 1989,
Michael Keaton's car.
Now, that's of course the one
that Tim Burton originally directed
and from the Nolan Trilogy,
the Bat statue.
It's probably kinda hard
to see the entire thing
but he's got no pants on.
Who would make a statue like that?
Now, clearly some of the
absolute most imposing things
in this exhibit,
look behind you,
the tumblers from The Dark Knight Trilogy.
Now, this is where Christopher Nolan
took over directing.
And you can really see the
realistic aspect of Batman.
These are the real deal.
They really run and
they are the originals.
They have Chevy 350, small
block V8 engines in there.
So, Bruce Wayne while, you know,
he is a really philanthropic guy
apparently the environment,
in terms of gas mileage,
not on his list of priorities
and that's fine.
Now, you see the camouflage tumbler
really make it's appearance
in The Dark Knight Rises
but the black tumbler really
carries it's way through
Batman Begins and The Dark Knight.
But behind me we're
gonna take a closer look
at The Joker Car.
Here we are,
inside of The Joker's car.
What an experience.
Look at this thing!
We've got valor all over the roof,
it's on the panels.
It's like blinged out to the max.
There's gold everywhere.
Gold shifter.
I don't know if you can see down there
but there are custom Joker mats.
There's like snake skin everywhere.
This thing has to be a
monster to actually clean.
But look at this diamond
encrusted steering wheel,
surprisingly good for grip.
I can see why he has that.
It's amazing.
And you know, reinforced roof.
Because at some point,
it's bound to happen,
somebody dressed up as a bat
is going to land right on the roof,
punch a hole through the thing,
rip The Joker out.
Tight quarters, too.
I can see he gets really
nuzzled up to Harley Quinn.
It makes it really easy for a
romantic date night, you know.
Man, I gotta get me one of these.
That's gonna do it for me.
Again, everybody,
thank you for checking out
some of my favorite things
but we encourage you to
come see for yourself.
So, join us, book your
tickets at wbstudiotour.com.
What else can I say about this exhibit,
besides the fact that it's the
Bane of my existence.
Don't just bring your nuclear family
because this place is
the bomb.
I am so sorry.